israelis gathered in tel aviv to watch a
speech that vladimir zelinsky had wanted
played to politicians inside israel's
knesset but with the parliament in
recess its members joined from wherever
they were by zoom the significance
remained a jewish president fighting a
war in europe appealing to what he set
out as a sense of shared history
our history and our survival and world
war ii listen to the words of the
kremlin they used the terminology of the
nazi party so it's a tragedy that they
wanted to exterminate all europe they
did not want to spare any one of you and
now any of us they call this the final
solution
but it wasn't long before ukraine's
president pivoted to the present and the
israeli government's current policy
israel's prime minister naftali bennett
has presented himself and his country as
a neutral mediating force talking
frequently to both zolensky and putin
never far from the surface israel's
interest in keeping russia on side
continuing to allow israel to carry out
airstrikes in syria unopposed
is it indifference calculation or
mediation without choosing sides i leave
it to you to choose the answer to this
question i only note one thing that
indifference kills calculations often
turn out to be wrong and mediation is
only possible between countries but not
between good and evil zielenski went on
to chide israel for not adopting
sanctions against russia or sending any
of its high-tech weaponry which he said
could save ukrainian lives for weeks now
israel's government has been arguing
that its neutrality on the war allows it
access to both sides an honest broker
facilitating negotiations but president
olensky through the strength of his
criticism has really exploded that
argument now criticizing almost every
aspect of israel's policy on the war
it's not the first time he's used such a
parliamentary address in recent days to
attack that country's policy but there
was an undoubted edge to his words
israeli ministers were quoted in the
local media criticizing what they called
his outrageous comparisons with the
holocaust the official line came from
israel's foreign minister repeating his
condemnation of the attack on ukraine
and thanking its president for sharing
his feelings and the plight of the
ukrainian people harry fawcett
al-jazeera west jerusalem